[Applaudissements]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour et
bienvenue sur le plateau dè maintenant
l'émission qui revient avec plaisir et
avec vous sur l'actualité politique de
la semaine vous connaissez le principe
hashtag et maintenant si vous souhaitez
réagir sur ce plateau cette semaine que
des numéro 10 de l'analyse politique ils
ont été triés sur le volet on retrouve
avec grand plaisir celui qu'on appelle
le redoutable Jean-Luc Manot est avec
nous bonjour Jean-Luc vous êtes
conseiller en communication fondateur du
cabinet h conseil à côté de vous on
salue Juliette madel bonjour bonjour
ancienne ministre présidente du
Mouvement l'avenir n'attend pas je
renvoie à votre livre un impérieux
besoin d'agir vous avez publier ça à
l'observatoire Nicolas bavrez bonjour
bonjour vous êtes économiste et
éditorialiste votre dernier livre
s'intitule démocratie contre empire
autoritaire c'est à retrouver aux
éditions de l'Observatoire et asilis LEC
bonjour vous êtes journal journaliste o
JDD merci d'être avec nous dans cette
émission on se demandera ce que peut la
diplomatie face à l'engrenage de la
guerre au Proche Orient on se demandera
si Jean-Luc Mélenchon est devenu le
problème de toute la gauche on verra si
la vérité des faits importe un cor dans
un moment comme celui que nous vivons
actuellement on se penchera enfin sur
l'augmentation inquiétante des actes
antisémites sur notre territoire la
séance est ouverte merci président
Larcher mais d'abord l'Europe face au
terrorisme islamiste 3 ans après la
décapitation de Samuel pati un
professeur de français Dominique Bernard
a été tué à coup de couteau dans son
collège d'aras quelques jours plus tard
la barbarie frappé Bruxelles où deux
suédois ont été abattus en pleine rue
face à ces événements Emmanuel Macron
assure que le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé écoutez-le tous les
États européens sont
vulnérables et il y a un retour en effet
de ce terrorisme
islamiste et nous avons tous une
vulnérabilité c'est celle qui va avec
des démocraties des états de droit vous
avez des individus qui à un moment
peuvent décider de commettre le pire et
nous avons là aussi durant le premier
mandat que j'ai effectué massivement
investi sur le suivi des profils les
plus dangereux et sur leur expulsion
donc là-dessus je n'ai pas vu de
défaillance de nos services je vous
propose ce sondage sur la perception de
la menace terroriste par les Français 84
% d'entre eux se disent inquiet dont 33
% très inquiet suite aux attaques
terroristes plus de 4 français sur 10
ont l'intention de changer leur
comportement s'agissant de leur vie
quotidienne et des sorti Jean-Luc c'est
exactement ce que veulent les
terroristes
oui parce que le le les les actions
terroristes les actes terroristes ils ne
sont pas strictement dépendants ils sont
ça joue mais ils sont pas strictement
dépendant du conflit
israélo-pestinien la la la la fonction
les haines sont multiples dans dans dans
la dans la matrice terroriste islamiste
il y a la haine des Juifs naturellement
on y reviendra mais il y a la haine de
la démocratie il y a la haine d'un mode
de vie du mode de vie occidental il y a
la haine de de d'un groupe de jeunes qui
va écouter de la musique il y a la haine
de la possibilité de boire un verre en
terrasse c'est-à-dire d'un d'un d'un
mode de vie qu'il juge haïssable et
qu'ils veulent détruire et c'est vrai
que le comme le nom l'indique c'est
c'est l'idée de de de la terreur
et euh le peuple français il est à la
fois euh dans on voit dans ce sondage
inquiet et on peut on serait à moins
mais il a toujours été formidablement
résilient c'est-à-dire qu'il n'a jamais
cédé là-dessus il ne s'est pas confiné à
ces moments-là il est même quand il l'
fallu aller manifester dans la rue il a
même été après la la la les attentats du
du Bataclan euh euh il y avait plus de
monde aux terrasses des des cafés parce
que c'était à la fois euh
continuer la vie et une forme d'acte
militant que d'aller prendre un verre là
où des gens ne supportent pas qu'on le
fasse j'aimerais dire ce que vous
venenez de dire c'est pas uniquement lié
au conflit au Proche Orient c'est
d'ailleurs ce que ce que disait un peu
ellisabeth bne vous êtes d'accord
Juliette c'est pas ce à quoi on assiste
aujourd'hui n'est pas uniquement lié à
ce qui se passe en ce moment au Proche
Orient entre Israël et le Hamas non ça
n'est pas uniquement lié au conflit au
proche- Orient ça fait 10 ans
aujourd'hui que les attentats de
Toulouse Montauban ont eu lieu je
rappelle Mohamed Mera qui tue des
enfants dans les au aratora et qui tue
des militaires ça fait 10 ans que le
terrorisme islamiste s'est installé sur
le territoire français on été suivi
après les attentats de Toulouse monauban
ont eu lieu tous les attentats que nous
connaissons donc des attentats de masse
jusqu'à l'attentat de Nice et puis il y
a eu d'autres attentats régulièrement et
pas qu'en France donc on s'est installé
dans une dans un dans un moment qui dure
depuis 10 ans moi j'ai un fils de 10 ans
voyez il n'a connu que la menace
terroriste il n'a connu que Vig pirate
il n'a connu
h mais peut-être que notre vigilance a
un peu baissé aussi on avait
l'impression qu' que la menace avait un
peu diminuéou oui parce que dieu merci
nous n'avons pas été victime d'attentat
de masse depuis quelques années et
dites-vous bien que la société met
environ 9 mois c'est un calcul fait par
un sociologue au moment où je m'occupais
de de l'aide aux victimes on avait
mesuré ça la France toute société mais
environ 9 mois après un attentat de
masse pour commencer à se remettre
psychologiquement donc là ça fait en
effet quelques années que nous n'avons
ont pas subi d'attentat de masse mais la
menace est présente elle est là elle est
structurellement présente et ça n'est
pas seulement à cause du conflit Isra
avait été ministre en charge de l'aide
aux victimes notamment Nicolas on a été
un peu naïf je mets bien sûr des
guillemets mais la menace qui diminu on
avait on s'était un peu installé dans
une sorte de normalité ce qui s'est
passé c'est que c'est vrai qu'on avait
diminué la menace avec quand même la
défaite de l'État islamique au au au
Levant et donc pendant un temps on sait
que que la
capacité de ces organisations à projeter
des commandos armées comme ça avait été
fait pour le le Bataclan avait disparu
aujourd'hui on sait qu'elle est en train
de se reconstituer à partir du Sahel
puisque maintenant on va avoir un énorme
sahéistant qui va se qui va se se se
former et c'est vrai que par ailleurs on
a néanmoins eu la un terrorisme
endémique intérieur qui a qui a continué
à à à frapper de de temps en temps et il
est certain que ce qui s'est pass passé
euh donc le la l'attaque du Hamas du 7
octobre a été un aussi est un
déclencheur donc on voit très bien que
évidemment l'onde de choc elle sert à
essayer de terroriser l'adversaire
Israël mais aussi les démocraties puis à
mobiliser son camp et dans le la
mobilisation il y a la mobilisation de
la partie radicalisée des communautés
musulmanes en en Europe à preuve
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas qu'en France
comme vous l'avez rappelé il y a la
également la la Belgique et là où nous
avons été sinon naïf du moins
clairement inefficace et et et pour le
moins léger c'est que l'interpellation
de la sœur de Samuel paatti elle est
elle est tout à fait
juste qu'avons-nous fait depuis réponse
en réalité rien et une fois de plus on a
entendu des mots du président de la
République mais ce sont des mots qui
sonnent complètement dans
le et qui sont déconnectés du R la suite
ag là pour 6 Français sur 10 l'exécutif
ne met pas en œure tous les moyens
nécessaires pour lutter contre la menace
terroriste il y a une sorte de laxisme
du côté du gouvernement en tout cas
c'est ce que dit la droite je sais pas
si on peut parler de laxisme c'est vrai
que je pense qu'il faut être assez
précautionnux là-dessus moi j'ai entendu
la semaine dernière manuel Vals qui a
été pris à parti puisqu'il était
ministre de l'Intérieur au moment où
cette famille la famille du du
terroriste d'aras a a pu rester en
France après l'intervention d'un certain
nombre d'associations pr migrant manuel
Val sa défense et il l' redit dans le
JDD semble tout à fait entendable
c'estàdire il dit c'était une famille
avec des enfants intégrés qui allaient à
l'école là on commence à voir en en
effet d'autres éléments qui montrre que
les professeurs ont été menacés qu'il
expliquait ce terroriste enfin qui
posait des questions pour savoir comment
fariquit des bombes artisanales enfin VO
il y a un ensemble d'élément quand même
qui pose
questions et à ce niveau-là on peut
légitimement je crois se demander s'il y
a une défaillance politique et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on est obligé si
on ne veut pas vivre dans la terreur
c'est d'avoir des lois peut-être
d'exception pour nous protéger euh merci
pour la transition on va arriver
effectivement sur le dossier législatif
parce que le gouvernement veut durcir
l'arsenal législatif en matière
d'immigration selon lui la loi qui sera
discutée au Parlement à partir de début
novembre aurait permis d'éviter cet
attentat d'arace écoutterz Gérald
darenin le texte immigration tel que
nous l'avons proposé et adopté par la
commission des Lois du Sénat euh nous
aurait permis de pouvoir obtenir la
levée des protections du terroriste
d'aras qui à l'époque n'était pas
considéré comme auteur terroriste c'est
vrai ça
Juliette je honnêtement la législation
de l'époque permettait au préfet de
prendre des décisions
d'expulsion en l'occurrence il y avait
le fait que le terroriste de l'époque
était en effet arrivé sur le sol
français alors même qu'il était mineur
et que ces conditions légal
av avant 13 ans et que donc du coup ces
conditions ces conditions là n'étaient
pas réunies pour qu'il puisse partir
mais manuel Vals avait quand même donné
au préfet la possibilité de prendre des
décisions d'éloignement qui aurait
peut-être donner lieu à des recours
devant les juridictions administratives
mais qui aurait qui auraiit quand même
pu effectivement le conduire à
l'expulser moi je je tiens quand même il
faut durcir cet arsenal législatif c'est
la question aujourd'hui le texte arrive
le 6 novembre au Sénat on va en parler
dans les semaines qui vienne est-ce
qu'il faut durcir cet arsenal législatif
moi je pense qu'il faut durcir l'arsenal
législatif à une limite c'est qu'il faut
respecter la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme parce que voyez si on
se met à dire que nos textes internes
peuvent s'affranchir du respect de nos
textes internationaux ce sont les
terroristes qui vont gagner deuxième
sujet sur lequel j'aimerais bien qu'on
revienne 2 secondes je crois quand même
que la question de l'aide aux victimes
n'est pas un Odine et qu'il faudrait
remettre en place un service public de
l'aide aux victimes parce que nous
sommes à nouveau entrés dans une a où
nous sommes très menacés maître bavrez
est-ce qu'on peut durcir cet arsenal
législatif tout en préservant l'État de
droit c'est ce que dit julette mais là
je je je je nuancerai peut-être ce qui a
été dit c'est-à-dire que le je ne crois
pas du tout que il faille lutter contre
le terrorisme par des lois d'exception
je pense que il faut déjà les appliquer
et ce qui a été dit quand on met par
exemple en cause le le droit européen il
faut quand même si si comment expliquer
à ce moment-là que en Allemagne 70 % des
octtf sont exécutés l' obligation de
quitter le territoire voilà en France
c'est euh entre 7 et 9 %. bon un
problème d'exécution c'est le même c'est
le même droit européen on peut pas dire
que le euh on est en Allemagne un état
qui soit caractérisé par la la la
répression et que c'est certainement pas
un état un état policier donc il y a
bien un problème sur la manière dont en
France on n'applique pas la loi et c'est
vrai que la situation de cette famille
elle est absolument extravagante on a le
père qui a donc finalement été expulsé
mais toute la famille est radicalisée un
certain nombre de d'entre eux ont été
condamnés ils sont en situation
irrégulière ils ont été débouté du droit
d'asile ils sont logés dans des logés
dans des logements sociaux et mais on on
on est il faut bien reconnaître que on
on parlait de mais là on n plus dans le
laxisme on est dans un système parce que
pour le coup ça ça peut pas se justifier
par l'État de droit donc là où je pense
que effectivement on a sûrement des
choses à
revoir notamment la l'incroyable
multiplicité des voies de recours ça
c'est ça c'est pas normal qu'on puisse
avoir 12 rendre notre système plus
efficace il y a une douzaine de de droit
de recours donc qui a des recours oui
mais il faut qu'il ait un juge et puis
avec un encadrement strict des dé la
recette la méthode pour pour appliquer
les textes c'est pas de faire de
nouveaux textes or c'est ce qu'on nous
dit à chaque fois dans le cas de cette
famille de la saillante d'aras la loi
permettait l'expulsion on a cédé à la
pression d'un certain nombre
d'associations dont le parti communiste
local qui sont venus là et qu'on dit il
faut pas pour des raisons parce qu'il y
a la scolarisation et cetera et il y a
une décision politique qui a été prise
manuel Val l'a reconnu il dit à ce
moment-là nous avons décidé de de ne pas
procéder à l'expulsion
donci d'accord il y a pas besoin d'une
nouvelle loi pour faire appliquer une
loi qui
existe de le faire la deuxième chose
c'est que il faut être honnête avec les
les les avec les Français sera bien que
les politiques le Soi le terrorisme
islamiste ce n'est pas la panage des
populations immigrées arrivé
illégalement en France ou légalement
enfin vous avez un nombre de bons
Bourguignons de
bons dauphinois ou excusez-moi pour les
deux régions concernées elles sont pas
particulièrement visées mais qui sont où
il y a des convertis ils sont en général
pas plus tendres que les autres et qui
le font donc le problème de notre
défense globale face au terrorisme il ne
peut pas être dans une obsession de
l'expulsion maintenant est-ce qu'on peut
le faire plus en fonction de la loi la
réponse est oui je veux dire une
dernière chose c'est
que il y a des gens qui nous disent
c'est l'état de droit qu'il faut jeter
par-dessus bord évidemment non parce que
sinon on vit on vit comme les autres ont
envie de nous nous imposer comme ils
vivent eux les terroristes mais en même
temps mais en même temps mais en même
temps l'État de droit c'est pas un truc
figé c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un
texte sacré l'état de loi on peut la
changer on change les constitutions on
peut changer un certain nombre de
dispositif une dizaine de jours en tout
cas les autorités constatent une
recruence recrence inquiétante des actes
antisémites en France ce mardi le
ministre de l'Intérieur a effectué un
déplacement à créteille à la rencontre
de la communauté juive il a tenu à faire
passer un message de fermeté écoutez-le
lorsqu'on s'en prend au juif en France
on s'en prend à la République on s'en
prend à ceux à qui nous devons
protection et on s'en prend bien
évidemment à l'idée que nous nous
faisons d'un pays à la liberté de culte
à la liberté Dero croire à la liberté de
s'exprimer à la liberté de porter un
vêtement religieux dans la voie publique
et personne ne touchera un cheveux d'un
juif de France sans attendre la réponse
foudroyante de l'État asilis dans la
conscience collective on avait un peu
l'impression que l'antisémitisme avait
disparu bah c'est pas le cas du tout bah
dans la conscience collective ça j'en
sais rien moi j'ai l'impression quand
même que mes amis juifs que de
nombreuses personnalités ont interpellé
ces dernières années l'affaire mirk Nool
l'affaire Sarah Alimi euh c'est
simplement un antisémitisme qui est
différent de l'antisémitisme qu'on a pu
connaître notamment pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale mais j'étis voir les
chiffres en 99 il y avait il y a eu 82
actes antisémites recensés et après la
seconde Intifada donc en 200000 il y a
743 actes antisémites donc on voit que
ça explose et que cet antisémitisme là
est évidemment un antisémitisme lié à
des populations et sur l'immigration
arabes musulmanes et c'est c'est c'est
un un antisémitisme qui est évidemment
fondé sur des bases religieuses aussi et
qui existe chez nous parce qu'il y a des
populations i sur l'immigration qui on
la haine du Juif non enfin excusez-moi
je peux pas pardon ne pas ne pas réagir
à ça d'abord un oui l'antisémitisme
augmente en France de de façon
dramatique et après la choix on on on on
ne peut pas supporter de voir une
augmentation des acantisémite donc c'est
le premier point deuxème point moi en
tant que femme de gauche j'aurais bien
aimé entendre et Olivier fort premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste et plein
d'autres et d'ailleurs ils l'ont fait
François Hollande Bernard casneuve dire
on ne touchera pas un cheveux à un un
juif de France ou d'ailleurs parce que
c'est contraire à nos principes trois et
c'est quand même aujourd'hui un point
qui est tout à fait fondamental on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui continuer à vivre
dans un pays où les Juifs ont peur ont
peur comme il ils ont eu peur au moment
des derniers attentats j'en parlait de
hosaratora et donc il faut que les
mesures soient renforcées drastiquement
des mesures de protection et dernier
point attention à ne pas mettre dans le
même panier les musulmans de France et
les terroristes islamistes c'est majeur
dans notre République on doit protéger
tout le monde et en France on ne peut
pas aujourd'hui considérer les gens en
fonction de leur origine on ne peut pas
désigner à la vindicte populaire des
populations en fonction de leur origine
on doit considérer tout le monde en
fonction de sa citoyen fr va dans le
sens de ce que vous dites toutes les
deux 48 % des Français considèent que
juifs sont plus en danger que les autres
citoyens c'est un sondage Ifop pour
précisément le JDD en date du 13 octobre
ils sont vraiment plus en danger que les
autres les les citoyens juifs bah oui il
suffit de regarder ce qu'on a dit la
recrudesence des actes antisémites ça
c'est quelque chose d'objectif c'est
suivi et et clairement ça augmente et
puis on l'a vu depuis donc les Français
sont conscients de cette augmentation de
absolument les Français sont conscients
mais la grande différence qui vient de
c'est que pendant enfin depuis la fin du
19e siècle antisémitisme était euh à
droite et à l'extrême droite et il a
basculé à gauche et à l'extrême gauche
donc ça c'est c'est ça le fait politique
majeur dans notre pays et c'est ça qui
qui change beaucoup puisque le le le
musulman a remplacé le le le le
prolétaire dans l'univers marxiste
maintenant c'est le musulman qui est le
Dané de la terre qui doit être défendu y
compris et j'allais dire et c'est là où
c'est très grave c'est-à-dire et et
c'est là où on sort de de de de l'arc
républicain et y compris euh en
pratiquant la violence et y compris en
pratiquant une violence extrême et puis
la deux le grand changement qu'on va
retrouver par ailleurs c'est qu'
évidemment dans cette violence
antisémite les réseaux sociaux ont tout
changé là encore puisque qu'est-ce de
résonance mais aussi possibilité de
passer à l'acte puisque on peut aller
envoyer des vidéos sur euh euh sur tel
jeune on peut appeler euh euh au meurtre
de son voisin de palier on peut
d'ailleurs et on peut mettre en scène
tout ça et en être fier donc on a il
faut jamais ou que sur sur la violence
et la manière dont la violence imprène
la société et où l'antisémitisme not
sait que c'est un très bon thermomètre
de la violence dans une société c'est
vrai que ça a beaucoup changé jeanl sur
la nature de l'antisémitisme oui je suis
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit à une
petite correction de vocabulaire pour
pour moi l'antisémitiste n pas basculer
de l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
il s'est répondu à l'extrême gauche il
s'est dans une certaine mesure hélas
démocratiser il a il est il est allé
dans d'autres sphères ça ne veut pas
dire que l'extrême droite est exente
aujourd'hui d'accusations sur les
questions de l'antisémitisme il suffit
de rappeler quel est l'entourage proche
de Marine Le Pen avec les gens qui la
conseillent ou qui travaillent sur sa
communication on voit bien que le le
ménage n'a pas été n'a pas été
totalement fait en tout cas pour parler
comme Nicolas Sarkozy il y a pas eu de
carcher on l'a fait au plus beau le fait
que le CRIF accepte d'inviter ou la
présence du RN à une de ces
manifestations vous conviendrez que ça
change
ré mais
l'apparencef a dit qu'il refusait
toujours de parler avec le rassemblement
national mais que la rue était libre et
qu'il ne pouvait pas interdire d'une
manière ça c'est la première chose mais
on voit bien qu'on est dans une
banalisation extrêmement dangereux quand
vous êtes un parti politique et que vous
invitez à vos universités d'été un
rappeur antisémite qui a fait des
déclarations antisémite vous donnez
l'autorisation de l'acte et du propos
antisémite donc de la violence
antisémite et ça on en a des des des des
des preuves qui sont hélas multiples
donc oui la
responsabilité d'une partie de la gauche
qui était jusqu'à il y a pas si
longtemps une une espèce de rempart
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
elle a totalement arrêté de jouer ce
rôle honte à elle alors on parle on
parle beaucoup de la France mais
l'augmentation des actes antisémites ne
se constate pas qu'en France en
Allemagne une synagogue à cette semaine
été attaquée au cocktail molotop c'était
à Berlin les autorités s'inquiètent
d'une flambée des actes dirigés contre
les Allemands de confession ou d'origine
juive même chose en Grande-Bretagne
écoutez ce Rabin de la ville de
Londres au cours de la semaine dernière
les incidents antisémites ont quintuplé
votre solidarité en vous levant et en
vous exprimant clairement contre toutes
les formes d'antisémitisme et d'intimid
antisémite en cette période extrêmement
douloureuse revait une grande
importance c'est un phénomène qui
dépasse largement la France ça dépasse
la France c'est une menace mondiale et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il fallait
que au moins le leader de la France
insoumise désolé de reparler de lui
Jean-Luc ou mais restons on va en
reparler après de la France insoumise
mais vraiment restons sur sur ça sur
cette menace qui touche toute la la
France toute l'Europe et même aussi à
l'international dans certains pays
arabes mais c'est une réalité ça a été
constaté par les faits ça a même
constaté été constaté aux États-Unis
c'est la la réponse politique à ça c'est
une condamnation qui doit être unanime
et qui ne doit certainertainement pas
être mise en balance ou être
contextualisé avec ce qu' se passe en
Israël le les actes qui ont été commis
le 7 octobre sont des actes d'une telle
importance qui représentent pour Israël
plus encore que le traumatisme du 11
septembre aux États-Unis mais ces actes
terroristes du Hamas contre Israël
trouvent une résonance évidemment un
contexte particulier et les gens qui
commettent ces actes et bien regardent
ce qui se passe en Israël et peut-être
sont incités plus rapidement ou en tout
cas sont incité à passer à l'acte oui il
y a eu l'OND de choc mais ce que je
voudrais rappeler parce qu'effectivement
même si la France est particulièrement
exposée parce que c'est la après le les
États-Unis c'est la deuxième pays où la
communauté juive en dehors d'Israël est
la plus importante et parce que on on
sait qu'on a aussi une très importante
communauté de de musulmans mais et ce
qui est important à dire c'est et c'est
là où de rappeler que le problème de
l'antisémitisme c'est pas le problème
des Juifs c'est le problème de tout le
monde parce que dans notre histoire si
vous regardez la fin du 19e siècle les
années 30 à chaque fois qu'il y a une
grande crise démocratique à chaque fois
que la crise devient intérieure et que
la violence s'étend l'antisémitisme je
le répète c'est le meilleur baromètre de
la désintégration d'une démocratie et du
basculement dans un climat de guerre
civile et donc il faut entendre ça et
malheureusement c'est vrai que le fait
que cet antisémitisme soit mondial et et
et monte dans toutes les démocraties
c'est un signal d'alerte qui doit
interpeller tous les citoyens des
démocraties et pas seulement les Juifs
cette semaine la France insoumise a de
nouveau suscité la polémique pour ses
positions sur les événements en proche
orient le bilan continue d'augmenté plus
de 1400 personnes ont été tuées dans les
attaques du Hamas contre Israël un
journaliste a demandé à la député à la
fille Daniel auonau si l'organisation
islamiste était un mouvement de
résistance écoutez sa réponse c'est un
groupe politique islamiste qui a une
branche armée et qui s'inscrit dans les
formations politiques palestiniennes
c'est un mouvement
résist a pour objectif la libération de
de la Palestine et qui résiste à une
occup c'est un mouvement de résistance
oui et oui c'est un mouvement de
résistance est- que vous pensez des
propos qui ont suscité l'indignation de
la quasittalité de la classe politique
la première ministre ellisabeth borne a
pointé du doigt la position des insoumis
écoutez
là depuis le 7
octobre les voix de la France insoumises
manquent à la condamnation unanime de la
barbarie terroriste elle manque à
l'unité nationale vous avez tenté de
justifier vos ambigué mais ce matin la
réalité est apparue au grand jour la
justice et
elle tranchera mais en entendant ces
propos je pense à ces jeunes tuer lors
d'une fête je pense à ces massacres dans
les kibuts de Berry et de karaza je
pense à ces femmes ces hommes ces
personnes ces personnes âgées et ses
enfants enlevés pour vous ce ne sont pas
des actes terroristes pour moi vous vous
excluez du champ républicain vous vous
excluez du champ républicain bon elle y
va un peu fort peut-être premire
ministre là-dessus moi j'ai tendance à
penser que c'est assez modéré la
déclaration de la première de la
première ministre face à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre enfin écoutez je sais que la
caractéristique de Madame obono c'est
qu'alos tout c'est ça qu'on la reconnaît
mais malgré tout on est dans un dans on
est dans encore en train de de sortir
les derniers morts d'un acte qui n'a pas
de précédent dans les 50 dernières
années on dit c'est le moment moment où
il y a eu un assassinat massif de Juifs
parce qu'ils étaient juifs le plus
important depuis la Choa et on on se
pose la question qui fait ça et pourquoi
fait ça et c'est un sujet qu'il faut
qu'il faut naturellement traiter les
historiens les les observateurs le font
et on a quelqu'un qui nous dit c'est la
résistance c'est-à-dire qu'elle nous
elle prend un des mots les plus nobles
qui existe et qui en plus pour des
Français renvoie un concept la
résistance à une histoire bon et Madame
bon pensé que le que le Cher patron du
du du euh du ramas c'est Jean Moulin et
c'est pas Jean Moulin c'est Barbie et en
France on n'honore pas Barbie on honore
Jean-Moulin et la confusion est
inacceptable elle est elle est elle est
honteuse elle est criminelle d'un
certain point de vue parce que c'est une
forme de révisionnisme par rapport au
mot résistance et c'est insupportable
asilise là-dessus peut-être pour qu'on
prenne comment vous interprétezv cet
entêement d'une partie de la France
insoumise sur ces termes on est voilà on
est dans des des termes des mots très
sensibles il y a eu beaucoup de morts
pourquoi cet entêtement selon vous alors
c'est un terme qui me déplaisait parce
que je déteste qu'on qu'on jette des des
anathèmes à la figure de nos adversaires
politiques je pense que il faut du
dialogue mais
là je crois qu'on peut dire que ce sont
des islamo gauchistes et ce terme
paraissait vraiment caricatural avant
aujourd'hui je je faisais partie de ceux
qui n'osaient pas l'employer et là je
crois qu'on ne peut pas passer à côté il
y a en effet d'abord un clientélisme un
électoralisme de la part de la France
insoumise qui rappelons-le 69 % de
l'électorat selon l'ifope des banlieu a
voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc il a
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a peur de froisser un
électorat éventuel euh il y a évidemment
cela et et puis il y a un fond
d'antisémitisme dans une partie de la
gauche à l'extrême gauche je dirais
assez prignant qui se qui se déguise en
antisionisme et sous prétexte de prendre
part à la cause palestinienne finalement
n'os même pas nommer ce qu'il est
c'est-à-dire les actes terroristes et
une organisation qui est terroriste
c'est quand même dingue et j'ajoute
qu'une partie de la gauche qui découvre
un peu la lune celle qui s'est alliée au
sein de la nupes à la France insoumise
collabore puisqu'on parlait de
résistance collabore de façon passive
euh à une gauche qui est très très
dangereuse pour alors il y a eu beaucoup
de réactions parce que la position de la
France insoumise suscite le malaise hein
sur les bands de la gauche les
communistes estiment que la nupè est
devenue une impasse les socialistes ont
quant à eux décrété un moratoire aux
réunions de groupe avec la France
insoumise Olivier fort le chef des
socialistes considère que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ne peut plus incarner la
gauche écoutez là où j'en rage c'est que
depuis une semaine de quoi parle-t-on on
parle exclusivement de la France
insoumise qui a refusé à un moment de
qualifier ce qui est pourant une
évidence le Hass d'organisation
terroristes mais il y a effectivement
une stratégie posée par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de tout conflictuel is de
faire en sorte que à tout moment il y
ait toujours un clivage net mais le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ne
Clive plus seulement la droite par
rapport à la gauche mais il Clive aussi
la gauche Juliette Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est devenu le problème de toute la
gauche entre guillemets mais pas
seulement Jean-Luc Mélenchon les
insoumis ce qu'il proposeent on voit
Daniel auonau mais il y en a bien
d'autres autour de alors certains ont
aussi condamné les propos en disant
qu'effectivement acte terroriste Hamas
contre Israël non mais il y a deux
choses d'abord la première c'est que la
réaction du premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste est très insuffisante quand
on a à faire face à d'une telle négation
de la réalité et à une telle quasiment à
une telle incitation à des actes
antisémites comme ce que les Jean-Luc
Mélenchon permet on coupe tout de suite
c'est-à-dire que on aurait pas dû dire
on fait un moratoire qui est reculé pour
mieux sauter Olivier fort aurait dû dire
c'est terminé on sort et nous n'avons
plus rien à voir avec les insoumis et il
aurait dû dire ensuite nous n'avons plus
rien à voir avec les insoumis parce que
le combat contre l'antisémitisme et le
racisme sont structurant de l'engagement
des socialistes et alors comment vous
expliquez qu'il n'y ait pas de rupture
nette et franche du côté des alliés de
la France insoumise Nicolas Azilis bah
parce que simplement ils sont pris dans
des des préoccupations tactiques mais
c'est vrai que c'est là on voit que le
la la réaction d'Olivier fort
complètement sa cible parce que il est
sur un terrain de petites politique
politicienne avec des jeux à l'intérieur
de la gauche le problème que POS des
c'est pas un problème politique c'est un
problème intellectuel et moral est-ce
qu'on peut effectivement justifier au
nom d'une idéologie décoloniale donc
assimiler
Israël simplement à un pays colonisateur
et donc accepter que parce que israël
est un pays colonisateur on peut
utiliser tous les moyens contre les
Juifs c'est ça le le le problème et si
vous voulez la position de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et de ses amis c'est la
préface de Sartre au livre de France
Fanon qui explique que quand on on tue
un européen on fait deux bonnes actions
parce que on libère euh on libère un
esclave et on tue un esclavagiste et
cette cette position si vous voulez elle
est intellectuellement et moralement et
aussi d'ailleurs politiquement
inacceptable pourquoi parce que
précisément on est dans un moment de
l'histoire où la violence est en train
d'exploser où on a un ensauvagement du
monde de nos sociétés donc tous ceux qui
pousse à la violence tous ceux qui
participent à cette libération dans le
monde démocratique que euh que ce soit
la position euh des Molas iraniens ou de
Vladimir Poutine je peux le comprendre
mais tous ceux qui sont dans les
démocraties et qui participe de ce
mouvement euh non seulement qui qui mais
mais qui l'incite qui le légitime et le
justifie cuxlà sont vraiment euh
moralement des des des des gens qui sont
indéfendables et c'est ça le problème
aujourd'huim de G parce que il faut être
juste dans la France insoumise on a
quand même des gens qui ont justement
pris conscience de ce caractère
inacceptable et qui ont pris certaines
distan comment vous expliquez-vous la
position de ces alliés de la France
insoumise pourquoi il y a pas de rupture
c'est parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
fait plus que 20 20 % à la
présidentielle et donc voilà il y a des
intérêts politiques a des socialiste
fait moins de 2 % évidemment ils ont
besoin de la nuupes pour avoir ensuite
un groupe à l'Assemblée nationale et
pouvoir qu à sacrifier des principes qui
à sacrifier ce que et quand il découvre
la lune il découvre vraiment la lune en
2019 Mélenchon est allé défiler avec le
CCIF à la marche contre l'islamophobie
des gens dans la rue on crié à l'bar et
en 2022 pendant la campagne il dit si
c'était à faire je le referaai si demain
il y avait une nouvelle marche j'irais
donc en fait il y a ça a toujours été
Mélanchon a compris depuis déjà quelques
présidentielles que son où était son
électorat potentiel et donc il a
évidemment rompu avec le discours qui
était le sien auparavant un discours
républicain pour simplement aller
chercher une nouvelle voie juste un
petit mot là-dessus c'est que vous voyez
ce machiavellisme à très courte vue je
pense que par ailleurs et c'est la d'une
certaine manière une bonne nouvelle mais
vous me détromperez je pense que c'est
un Paris à courte vue parce qu'en fait
les Français les citoyens français
savent très bien ce à quoi ça correspond
et qu'aujourd'hui la légitimation de la
violence y compris à gauche et même au
sein de la France insoumise on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ne sont pas prêts à accepter ça
parce qu'effectivement c'est moralement
inacceptableanl et après pas
il y a pas d'orientation théorique
fondamentale dans ce que fait la France
insoumise partie de la France insoumise
ben il a quand même décolonisé ou
oui j'y viens ils veulent ils veulent
ils veulent des sièges ils veulent des
des des voies dans en imaginant je pense
aussi à court terme parce que je pense
qu'ils perdront plus ici qu'ils ne
gagneront là mais c'est le résultat quoi
c'est le résultat de la synthèse
improbable d'une vulgade trosquiste et
de des des des des des la France
indigène la défense de l'indigénisme et
ça ça fait un bougi bouga quand même qui
n'est pas très cohérent du point de vue
du du du point de vue politique il y a
une espèce de de c'est il y a beaucoup
de quand même de de diarrê verbal dans
tout ça et qui permet toutes les
ouvertures l'ouverture à des fes je
disais de révisionnisme de négationnisme
parce que quand on appel résistant des
assassins des tueurs et et qu' confond
les les les victimes et et les et les
criminels on est dans une dans une dans
une errance AB c'est pas la gauche et ça
ça n'est pas la gauche la position oui
la position de la France insomise ça
n'est pas la gauche ça n'est pas la
gauche républicaine ça n'est pas la
gauche de François mitteran ça n'est pas
ça donc je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous la France insoumise là est en
train de tuer le Parti socialiste il est
déjà mort mais il y a une autre gauche
elle est peut-être minoritaire
aujourd'hui mais il y a une gauche
progressiste qui s'est exprimée par la
voix de de Bernard casenu ou de François
Hollande et il y a un électorat il y a
une partie de cet électorat de François
Hollande dont je suis qui a voté pour
Emmanuel Macron et qui ne supporte pas
ces positions qui sont des positions
antisémites et racistes les faits
ont-ils encore une importance ça
pourrait être une question du backacfilo
pour l'année prochaine question qui nous
est venue alors que cette semaine
plusieurs versions d'un même fait se
sont affronté mardi soir autour de 19h
une explosion est repérée dans un
hôpital de la bande de Gaza le Hamas
accuse Israël d'avoir effectué une
frappe l'armée israélienne de son côté
renvoie la responsabilité vers un autre
groupe islamiste palestinien allié du
Hamas qui aurait raté un tir de roquette
on recens au moins plusieurs dizaines de
morts les heures et les jours passants
plusieurs enquêtes réalisées par des
observateurs des expert des experts
indépendants indiquent que cette
dernière version est la plus
vraisemblable on y revient dans un
instant mais juste avant je vous propose
d'écouter ces deux versions qui se sont
opposés immédiatement après
l'explosion j'appelle tous les peuples
libres les Nations Unis le Conseil de
sécurité et l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies les institutions
juridiques appelle la Ligue arabe et
l'organisation de la coopération
islamique a condamné clairement ce
terrible massacre ce meurtre de masse et
la privation de notre sang de nos femmes
de nos enfants et de nos personnes âgées
ce silence doit
cesser les renseignements provenant de
plusieurs sources dont nous disposons
indiquent que le Djihad islamique est
responsable du tir de roquette raté qui
a touché l'hôpital à Gaza voilà malgré
le démenti rapide d'Israël les réactions
internationales condamnant les temp
l'État hébreux se sont multiplié des
rassemblements impressionnants lieu dans
la foulée dans plusieurs pays arabes
c'était le cas en Jordanie en Tunisie au
Liban en Syrie dans certains cas comme à
Aman les manifestants ont tenté de
s'introduire dans l'ambassade
israélienne où s'en sont pris à des
intérêts français comme en Tunisie ou
devant l'ambassade de Tunis Paris a été
accusé de soutenir Israël il y a eu un
démenti on est plusieurs jours après
maintenant on sait à peu près ce qui
s'est passé en tout cas il y a une
version qui est beaucoup plus probable
que l'autre mais finalement le mal est
fait Jean-Luc oui bien sûr que le mal
est fait on est dans aussi dans une
guerre de prop dans une guerre des
réseaux sociaux dans une
guerre de communication est-ce que les
faits ont encore c'était la question
vous posiez de l'importance
bah ils doivent continuer à en avoir
c'estàdire qu'il ne faut pas renoncer
malgré tout à à à parler des faits et et
à essayer de faire
voir des vérités moi je suis très frappé
de voir que ce cette maladie a atteint
que que ça atteignne le le le les les
les les belligérants on peut le
comprendre mais ça atteint la France
écoutez étaé stupéfait d'une d'une
séquence hier France
interre l'inévitable madame Panau est
invé oui jeudi JEI pardonors vous savez
quoi on va on va écouter math de Panau
et ensuite je donne parce que c'est
quand même extraordinaire alors on va
l'écouter je vous donne la parole après
alors je donne un peu le contexte
maltide pano qui est donc la chef du
groupe insoumis à l'Assemblée nationale
a vitagit précisément au drame de
l'hôpital un journal une journaliste lui
demande si elle a des informations
particulières permettant d'affirmer que
cette explosion est bien dû à une bombe
israélienne écoutez sa réponse le
gouvernement israélien a déjà menti à
plusieurs reprises et que dans les
guerres généralement les armées mes je
vais vous donner des exemples en 2009 le
gouvernement d'extrême droite xraélien
disait qu'il n'avait pas utilisé de
phosphore blanc pour ensuite admettre
devant les preuves qui avaient été
récolté par des ONG admettre en août
2009 qu'ils avaient utiliser du
phosphore blanc Jean-Luc c'est une c'est
une une rhtorique insensée c'est-à-dire
que l'ensemble des observateurs disent
non pas avec assurance mais disent il
semble que on est plutôt dans un tir
raté du du Djihad islamique d'autres
disent il est trop tôt pour se prononcer
madame pano dit je sais pourquoi elle
pourquoi pourquoi c'est-elle parce que
en général l'armée israélienne ment et
faut qu'elle ajoute la suite et le ramas
qui est la source ne m jamais c'est bien
connu que les terroristes du ramas
disent la vérité ça veut dire que sa
source à elle son AFP à elle son retare
à elle sa base d'information c'est le
ramasse elle accepte ça et à ce
moment-là madame Panau se comporte comme
un agent d'influence et de propagande du
ramas en reprenant cette référence comme
une référence au-dessus de tout j'ajoute
une petite chose c'est que l'armée
israélienne ment ça rappelle quand même
furieusement les Juifs sont par nature
des menteurs alors ce qui est vrai c'est
que les armées conventionnelles en état
de guerre souvent pas toujours mais
quand ils sont en situation de conflit
je précise aussi qu'à Gaza il n'y a pas
de journaliste indépendant donc il est
très difficile de vérifier tout ce qui
se passe actuellement mais comment vous
expliquez Nicolas qu'on soit pris dans
l'engrenage de ce conflit et qu'on
narrive pas à mettre de la distance à ce
qui est en train de se passer vous savez
on cette semaine c'est le le 40e
anniversaire de la disparition de
Raymond Haron et Raymon Haron disait une
opinion fausse peut devenir un fait
politique réel c'est exactement ce ce
qui se passe on est on est dans un
conflit asymétrique il est clair que sur
le plan militaire le Hamas euh et donc
le Hamas cherche à rééquilibrer les
choses et une manière de rééquilibré
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est la guerre de
l'information et c'est vrai que euh très
habilement le Hamas à partir des
massacres du 7 octobre on sait que
l'intervention terrestre de tsal dans la
dans la bande de Gazin dans un endroit
extrêmement dense et urbanisé bah
évidemment créer des des des victimes
civiles et le le Hamas fait la bascule
pour que le narratif du Hamas s'impose
sur le narratif israélien et c'est cette
affaire de l'hôpital qui a été misise en
scène et on est pris dedans parce que si
vous voulez l'onde de choc et c'est là
où le Hamas a quand même réussi son
Paris c'est que plus personne ne parlait
du conflit
israélo-palestinien depuis le 7 octobre
premièrement c'est redevenu le le centre
du monde deuxièmement la pression qui
est exercée sur tsal va contraindre les
les opérations militaires ça va sans
doute pousser à l'ouverture d'un
deuxième front à à la frontière
libanaise dorser déjà Joe Biden la
diplomatie son voyage a été déséquilibré
parce que la partie arabe n'a pas pu se
faire et par ailleurs l'onde de choc se
déroule dans le monde entier avec ce
qu'on a vu les manifestations et et
avec on peut pas utiliser de nuances
quand on regarde quand on observe ce
conflit et je pense que c'est une
réflexion plus globale doit avoir sur
l'exigence du débat démocratique et de
la conversation civique aujourd'hui on
sait que c'est compliqué les médias et
et je le sais Paris que je travaille au
Journal du dimanche mais sont des j'ai
travaillé au Figaro avant mais sont des
médias avec des lignes éditoriales qui
qui
s'adresse à des parfois des bulles
d'opinion nous ce qu'on cherche à faire
au Journal du Dimanche c'est d'avoir des
faits vérifiés même en ayant une ligne
éditoriale comme ce le cas quand j'étais
au Figaro que je publicité ce que non
mais ce que je veux dire par là et je je
pense c'est vraiment important de le
faire et l'écrit permet peut-être
parfois plus que les débats télévisés
saufici bien sûr mais parfois nous
sommes en fait dans une volonté de clage
dans une volonté d'opposition et et
c'est vraiment une réflexion qu'on doit
avoir quand je vois Mathilde panneau qui
que qui se permet d'affirmer des choses
qui ne sont donc pas des vérités
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle fait
finalement du mal à la démocratie parce
que on chche elle ne cherche pas à
savoir ce qui peut permettre de trouver
une vérité elle cherche simplement à
satisfaire un électorat à satisfaire les
bultes bulle de filtre de ceux qui vont
la retweeter sur ses réseaux sociaux ça
la réalité je pense que ce qui se passe
là c'est le signe que nos démocraties
vont très mal on a déjà eu ce débat là
au moment de la guerre de l'invasion
russe en Ukraine avec une
instrumentalisation par la France
insommise mais aussi par Erric Zemour
d'ailleurs et aussi par Marine Le Pen
des faits et donc on a comme ce qui
s'est passé au moment de l'élection de
Trump aux États-Unis des forces qui sont
des forces étrangères relayé par des
mouvements populistes et démagogues dans
notre pays qui ser sur ces fake news
pour faire de la propagande et prendre
le pouvoir h que ce soit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais ça a été Éric Zemmour au
moment des élections ça sera aussi sans
doute Marine Le Pen chacun essae
d'utiliser les événements extérieurs en
racontant n'importe quoi au détriment de
la démocratie pour servir sa cause
politique et c'est ça le drame et donc
la seule solution c'est le travail
d'éducation c'est le travail des
journalistes sérieux c'est le travail de
pédagogie que vous faites et que chacun
essaie de faire à sa mesure pendant ce
tempsl la guerre continue évidemment
Israël et le Hamas cette semaine
plusieurs leaders occidentaux se sont
envolés pour le proche orient afin
d'afficher leur solidarité avec les
Israéliens frappés par le terrorisme ils
ont également fait le déplacement pour
tenter de désamorcer l'escalade de la
violence
écoutez la justice doit être rendue mais
je vous mets en garde si vous ressentez
de la rage ne vous laissez pas envahir
par elle après le 11 septembre nous
étions horangé aux États-Unis nous avons
cherché à obtenir justice et nous
l'avons obtenu mais nous avons aussi
commis des
avant tout je tiens à exprimer ma
solidarité avec vous et votre pays après
avoir subi quelque chose d'innommable un
acte terroriste barbare et pour répondre
à votre dernier point nous devrions
l'appeler par son nom un acte de
terrorisme perpétré par une organisation
terroriste maléfique le Hamas
l'Allemagne et Israël sont unis par le
fait qu'ils sont des états
constitutionnels démocratiques nos
actions sont basées sur la loi et
l'ordre même dans des situations
extrêmes contrairement au Hamas qui veut
se servir des citoyens de Gaza comme des
boucliers humains nous nous préoccupons
d'eux également nous voulons protéger et
éviter les pertes civile Nicolas à quoi
servent toutes ces visites
alors la seule vraiment utile c'est la
visite de Joe Biden parce que les
États-Unis même diminués ont encore une
une capacité d'action importante donc
café Biden il a fait deux choses une
réassurance stratégique et diplomatique
très forte d'Israël avec la présence de
porte-avion et puis le prépositionnement
de de 2000 marines et il a fait une
autre chose c'est une sévère mise en
garde à Benjamin netanahou avec des
lignes rouges pour
l'intervention d'israëlupation gaz pas
d'occupation de
Gazin respect du droit international et
ouverture donc
le pour les convois humanitaires et
normalement un C humanitaire entre le
Nord et le Sud et la troisième chose qui
a été entendue le fait de ne pas céder à
la passion et d'être raisonnable côté
européen c'est une cacophonie sans nom
et ça n'a strictement aucun impact la la
question que je voudrais poser au-delà
de ce court terme parce que la vraie
question c'est est-ce qu'il va y avoir
une place pour la diplomatie pour dans
le règlement de ce conflit et et et on
comme souvent au Moyen-Orient on peut
passer du pire à parfois quelques
quelques fenêtres on peut espérer que si
le gouvernement natthanahou finit par
tomber après ce qui est quand même assez
probable il y aura en
Israël une fenêtre mais ça suppose
d'avoir un interlocuteur en Palestine ce
qui est pas le cas pour l'instant et ça
suppose peut-être et c'est l'autre
j'allais dire chose un peu positive que
des puissances régionales mais peut-être
là une Europe qui sortirait de ce
angélisme et de sa passivité au côté des
États-Unis puisse essayer de remettre en
route ce processus
Juliette peut faire la diplomatie c'est
ce que demande Nicolas peut la
diplomatie elle non seulement elle peut
tout mais surtout elle doit tout et la
solution ne doit être que diplomatique
par diplomatique j'entends un incord
international une intervention de l'ONU
une présence si possible de force
d'interposition pour éviter le bain de
sang parce que c'est ça qui va se passer
c'est ça qui est en train de se passer
c'est ce qui a eu lieu ces derniers
jours et deuxièmement Israël est la
seule démocratie euh dans la région dans
la région c'est la seule démocratie donc
il faut s'appuyer sur la mécanique
démocratique et soutenir c'est le
dernier point soutenir de toutes nos
forces la gauche progressiste
israélienne qui s'est battu contre
netaniaou qui a manifesté pendant des
jours entiers et qui n'a pas été à mon
sens assez soutenu donc il faut hélas
mais donc c'est ça qu'il faut faire
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut soutenir les
forces progressistes modérées
raisonnables pour aboutir à une solution
dipl c'est la seule solution Jean-Luc
vous la diplomatie dans l'immédiat
absolument rien si ce n'est organiser
des corridors essayer de faire qu' de
l'humanitaire dans le moment du fracas
dans lequel on parle
elle ne peut rien c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que le discours des gens qui
essayent de de camoufler le leur gène
sur le sujet et disent il faudrait
parler demain parler avec qui vous allez
mettre le gouvernement israélien face au
ramas avec quoi comme ordre du jour avec
quoi comme ordre du jour vous avez une
charte dans lequel vous dites vous
voulez éradiquer Israël et et supprimer
la présence de tout Juif sur place on
discute de quoi c'est quoi l'agenda il y
a un alinéa qui dit on discute savoir si
c'est mieux le couteau la hache le fusil
le gaz c'est ça quand même que certains
nous disent en disant il faut parler
immédiatement qu'ensuite évidemment il
n'y ait pas de solution militaire
définitive ça évidemment l'histoire la
dans cette
nous l'apprend il faudra bien sûr qu'il
y ait des négociations dernier mot que
je veux dire c'est que euh j'aurais aimé
voir le président de la République
française sur place affirmer sa
solidarité on nous dit qu'il ira trs
prainement oui on nous dit qu'il ira
prochainement mais comme il dit qu'il
ira quand il pourra faire bouger les
lignes c'est pas demain la veille qu' va
faire le voyage voyez il y a pas c'est
pas peine de réserver le billet d'avion
hein c'est ça ça va prendre ça va
prendre ça va prendre du temps donc non
la solidarité que les Européens
manifestent et j'espère que la situation
en France politique en France
n'interdira pas au président de la
République de se rendre en Israël parce
qu'on peut pas d'un côté accuser la
France insoumise de prendre des
positions insupportables parce qu'elle
cherche à gagner des voix dans un
certain nombre d'endroits et on peut pas
on pourrait pas tolérer de la même façon
du président de la République qu'il
n'aille pas sur place pour éviter d'en
perdre asilist qu'est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron peut faire pourrait faire
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de de sa
position dans dans dans ce conflit c'est
une ou
question la question la plus difficile
peut-être de cette émission oui en effet
euh donc euh je je n'y réponds pas
vraiment mais par contre la question que
je me pose et je n'ai évidemment pas non
plus la réponse c'est est-ce que la
solution de deux états est encore
possible aujourd'hui il semble quand
même que ça après cette attaque du Hamas
et le fait qu'il manque simplement une
une Autorité palestinienne forte avec un
représentant on sait que Marmoud Abbas
n'a rien obtenu de concluant ces
dernières années et qu'il est contesté
au sein de la population palestinienne
donc moi je je je je pose la question
que deviendra cette solution à deux
états est-elle encore possible nicolas
Vraiment j'aimerais avoir une réponse
sur le rôle de la France dans cette
histoire qu'est-ce que vous attendez
d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que peut le kéoré qu'est-ce que peut la
France dans cette région est-ce que il y
a encore des levier est-ce que il y a
quelque chose que est-ce qu'on peut
faire quelque chose si vous voulez
Emmanuel Macron s'est ridiculisé au
Liban déjà je le rappelle quand même
face au hzbola et et donc ce qui a été
dit est juste c'est-à-dire que la France
peut se peut faire deux choses elle elle
peut être solidaire d'une démocratie qui
a été attaquée et de de je rappelle que
on a quand même au passage un certain
nombre de citoyens français qui ont été
tués dans des conditions horribl ou qui
sont aujourd'hui détenus en otage donc
ça c'est la première chose et ensuite ce
que peut faire la France c'est rappeler
quand même cette position qui est
normalement la position traditionnelle
de il s'est pas intéressé au moyenori
Emmanuel Macron jusqu'à présent la
position française c'est une position
qui est assez juste je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on l'a dit la PR c'est le
temps des armes mais il faudra de toute
manière revenir à un temps de donc
premièrement condamnation de la violence
et du terrorisme et condamnation
intransigente deuxièmement droit à la
légitimité
de d'Israël de se défendre troisièmement
le droit international et le droit
humanitaire s'applique aussi à Israël
même si c'est dans des conditions qui
vont être très difficiles d'une
intervention dans une zone très urbanisé
et 4è point ça a été rappelé au-delà du
temps des armes qui va
venir ce qui est important c'est que on
ne perde pas de vue l'idée que il faut
une paix et et c'est ce qui a quand même
été rappelé de manière tragique c'est
que l'idée qu'il va y avoir une paix au
Moyen-Orient sans les Palestiniens c'est
une idée qu'on a essayer de mettre en
place et c'est une idée qui est fausse
et qui malheureusement s'est révélé
tragiquement fausse et donc là-dedans on
a le
problème de ces deux états côte à côte
souverain avec des conditions des
garanties de sécurité le problème
évidemment c'est de trouver un
interlocuteur côté palestinien pour
pouvoir discuter de cette solution et
cet interlocuteur ne peut pas être le
Hamas en tout cas le Hamas tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui merci merci excellence merci
diplô vous êtes un très bon diplomate
merci beaucoup Nicolas comme chaque
semaine on va terminer cette émission
par un un top flop je vous pose une
question très simple qui a marqué
l'actualité de cette semaine si
particulière en bien ou en mal Jean-Luc
vous commencez votre top de la semaine
oui le top c'est c'est Xavier Bertrand
parce que je l'ai trouvé sur les les
dans ses interventions sur la situation
au Proche Orient et en France équilibré
à la fois pas de pas d'hésitation dans
la condamnation du ramas et et en même
temps une volonté de de faire la
différence entre un projet et de loi sur
l'immigration et la bataille nécessaire
contre le terrorisme évitant de faire
des des des liens qui sont abusifs pas
de flop et ben c'est le c'est le
contraire c'est Olivier fort Olivier
fort parce que patron du du du du PS
parce que ENF il y a une mièvrerie
insensée quoi on voit les déclarations
de Madame auonau de Madame Panau de
Mélenchon et Olivier fort dit on va
peut-être s'éloigner un peu on prend du
temps et puis on va faire un un un un
moratoire et cetera enfin c'est c'est
insupportable un conseil
enfin il faut consulter il y a des
bonnes thérapies contre le syndrome de
Stockholm c'est un flop Juliette votre
top de la semaine c'est les élections en
Pologne puisqueen fait l'opposition
proeuropéenne a gagné les élections en
Pologne donc c'est une très bonne
nouvelle parce que ça ça renforce un peu
ce que nous sommes en tout cas ce que
nous essayons de construire et ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle et votre flop mais
c'est un communiqué de presse de la CGT
du Nord qui est sorti ce matin qui est
un tissu de propos antisémite et d'appel
à la haine et qui justifie au fond les
exactions du Hamas entre les lignes il
faut quand même souligner que l'auteur
de ce communiqué de presse est
aujourd'hui en garde à vue pour appel à
la haine et apologie du terrorisme
Nicolas votre top de la semaine Joe
Biden on l'a entendu tout à l'heure
c'est rare que les très grandes
puissances fassent leur m à coulep alors
certes c'était le camp d'en face mais je
crois que l'idée de rappeler que
l'Amérique s'est perdue dans des guerres
totalement déraisonnable après le 11
septembre en cédant à la passion et à la
rage au lieu d'essayer de construire une
stratégie qui soit une stratégie
raisonné et long terme je pense que
c'est utile très utile de le rappeler
aujourd'hui c'est utile pour Israël
honnêtement c'est très utile aussi pour
nous tous face à à l'Ukraine ou à la au
retour des des menaces stratég et votre
flop le flop ben j'allais dire il se
passe je crois qu'on en a parlé c'est
quand même madame auonau que nous avons
entendu tout à l'heure
h c'est plus un problème politique c'est
vraiment une une faillite une faillite
morale et qui emporte avec elle
effectivement tout l'entourage de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dont il est triste de
de de voir qu'il s'enferme dans cette
dans cette position qui est absolument
insoutenable asiliz alors moi mon flop
c'est michaell paatti qui est la sœur de
Samuel Patti qui était auditionnée
devant la commission d'enquête au Sénat
sur les agressions d'enseignants elle a
été impeccable méthodique elle a admis
avoir cédé elle-même pu un temps au
méandre je cite du politiquement correct
aujourd'hui elle constate qu'il n'y a
pas eu d'avant et d'après Samuel Patti
elle a été vraiment merveilleuse
j'invite tout le monde à aller écouter
ce long texte qu'elle a lu et et
espérons maintenant que nous l'avons
entendu qu'il y aura un après Dominique
Bernard tu t'as retrouvé en replay sur
public sénna je le rppelle votre flop de
la semaine et mon flop ce sont les actes
émite qui explose
euh je rappelle simplement les chiffres
déjà en 2021 589 436 en 2022 nous
verrons maintenant avec cette
réactivation du conflit
israëlo-palestinien les résultats de
l'année 2023 il y a déjà plusieurs
centaines d'actes antisémites qui ont
été recensé ces derniers jours et pas
seulement en France également en Europe
à Berlin des maisons ont été taguées
maisons de juifs ont été taguées avec
des étoiles de David des synagogues ont
été attaquées et donc voilà je veux
juste simplement qu'on qu'on pense à nos
concitoyens juifs qui sont attaqués
parce que juif et aussi parce que comme
nous représente l'Occident et peut-être
l'esprit européens qui souffl en Israël
et qui t'qu merci merci à tous les
Quates c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir participé salut à vous
derrière votre écran merci pour votre
fidélité vous êtes nombreux à réagir ces
dernières semaine à nous envoyer des
messages merci infiniment vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre plateforme publsenat.fr on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même jour
même heure et même endroit bye bye
[Musique]